there are just three days until the Iowa
caucus president Trump is trying to
steal the spotlight though from
Democrats there the president rallied
his supporters in Des Moines last night
and he mocked the Democratic candidates
and slammed his impeachment trial ed
O'Keefe is in Des Moines for us at good
morning so this is the official start of
the campaign season what's the mood like
in Iowa well Toni much like everything
else these days this is a little
different you know normally three days
out before caucus this would probably be
the lead story thanks to the impeachment
trial it isn't
thanks to the impeachment trial there
are a few candidates missing because
they're still serving on that jury and
the subject of that impeachment trial
well he showed up here last night
looking for votes in the past year Iowa
has been home to mostly Democratic
presidential candidates but last night
the man they want to beat showed up to
have had a front row seat to the lunacy
and the madness of the totally sick
ahead of mr. Trump's arrival with Joe
Biden called him out saying the
president lacks the moral character for
the job
he's more bully than president and he's
having an incredibly corrosive effect on
our nation with the senators running for
president stuck in Washington for the
impeachment trial the state has been
left to the non senators like Biden and
former mayor Pete Budaj who's trying to
elbow his way into the spotlight by
directly targeting the candidates at the
top here Vice President Biden saying
that this is no time to take a risk on
someone new then I hear senator Sanders
calling for a kind of politics that says
you've got to go all the way here and
nothing else counts when asked about
booted judges attack Biden swung back
saying he's had more voter support than
the small city mayor you guys have seen
Pete he's a good guy
you see Bernie you've seen me
you know I mean something's just
self-evident contrast you know I've got
more than 8,600 votes in my life as for
those senators running for president of
course they're stuck at the trial so if
there's a vote tonight the earliest we
might see them back on the campaign
trail is some point tomorrow but Tony
keep this in mind this is Kansas City
chief country so you're not gonna see
much campaigning on Sunday ahead of the
Superbowl meaning these candidates have
precious few hours left to reach voters
I bet I'll be at a Super Bowl party
there in Iowa myself on Sunday night ed
O'Keefe Orson thank you very much